alors ça va ton ventre non
la vache j'espère que ça va s'arrêter
je dois y aller de nouveau désolé des
courtes cette conversation
je vous préviens c'est assez le nom de
la chaîne ah oui là docteur pimpel
Popper ce qui veut dire donc bah docteur
j'éclate les boutons on y va attention
aux images ah non je regarde pas et
voilà donc là on a commencé un peu ça
avec un point noir
et là
tu as déjà fait caca depuis le début tu
es sérieuse ta page une seule fois j'ai
une dizaine de fois depuis qu'on est
arrivé ici
deux fois ce matin et genre 8 fois
l'autre jour
désolé je dois y aller j'ai envie de
[Musique]
partager
des légumes trop chou Bett
assez fierté pour ses passionnés de
potager qui se sont affrontés en
Angleterre afin de savoir qui avait la
plus
grosse la clé c'est quelque chose de
très chargée pour moi et puis mon enfant
elle a une valeur